and now I said at the start the show
that we've heard a lot about numbers and
data in the last few weeks so let's try
and make some sense of some of that
we're joined now by the chair of global
public health at Edinburgh University
professor Debbie Schroeder thank you so
much for coming on the program today now
it feels as if the number that the
government is talking about an awful lot
at a minute is the our number the rate
of infection and what measures of the
lockdown have the biggest impact on that
our number what kind of things do you
think the government could be looking at
tweaking in relation to our in the
coming week yes exactly
our is a really important number because
we have to keep it below 1 if it goes
above 1 basically means we'll see
exponential growth in cases again and
then likely have to take more drastic
measures to get it back beneath one
again and so the measures that are being
looked at or for example trying since we
looks like we are below 1 now is perhaps
you know letting some kind of outdoor
activities go ahead for example you know
looking at schools and how this might
affect that that facemasks now how might
that play anything it's very small as
well as the biggest chunk which might be
test trace isolate which is a way of
just quarantine enos who are carrying
the virus instead of quarantine
everybody we've talked quite a lot about
schools on the program they've been
reports that primary schools could
reopen and it feels as if there's some
dispute about how much children actually
spread coronavirus whether or not they
are big carriers that they can spread it
a lot even if they haven't got symptoms
what's your understanding on that yeah
exactly I think the consensus is that
children are carriers of the virus
because there was a time when we weren't
sure could they even carry it and now
the debate is over the degree to which
they can infect others and here of
course the concern is for teachers for
parents grandparents basically others
they might be exposing if they're you
know transmitting within a school
environment and so different governments
are taking different approaches to this
first based on actually how much risk
they want to take and are they gonna be
Aaron being more cautious you're gonna
hold back and wait to get more
information or do you feel like you know
we need to get schools back and so you
know you'll see countries like Denmark
opening schools and then keeping in
place monitoring to see how this
actually affects further spread I mean
it also depends where you are in terms
of
she you're our number if you have a lot
of wiggle room but not she you can do
these kind of you know small experiments
in the sentence to see actually can we
open schools for a limited amount of
time if you have a large number of cases
you don't have proper surveillance in
place you don't have a test trace
isolate strategy in place it's very hard
to open schools because actually if you
do set up a whole new set of cases then
it's harder to bring that under control
again we've also talked a bit about
older people as well just heard from a
Baroness Roz Altman who was effectively
saying it was age discrimination that
people above a certain age that should
not be allowed to see their friends and
family if the rest of the population do
and do you agree with that what's your
view on it yeah it's a really tricky one
because you know I really sympathize
with you know the idea of shielding
because it can also be seen as locking
people away and there has to be a better
way of doing this and so I think what we
really need to do is be getting out of
this situation where we're trying to
steal the vulnerable and actually really
aggressively go after the virus this
means actually having widespread testing
you know actually tracing contacts
actually figuring out you know through
surveillance systems as well of
geographically where is the virus within
the country because if you are finding
it there's certain parts the country
we're actually you know we have very low
numbers of cases or you know you have
more wiggle room and you're our number
then actually there could be ways to
actually move away from just shielding
you know elderly and vulnerable
individuals I mean it's also worth
noting that while we know at a
population level and we're learning more
about risk factors or you know you know
how it relates to the broad stroke level
we still don't know at the individual
level why it is it's still people in
their 20s and 30s who are healthy
especially in health care settings can
get severely ill from this so these are
still you know things we need to look at
so interesting to hear you say they're
about different parts of the country
perhaps having lower levels than others
of infection ray if that is the case do
you think that there is an argument that
the lockdown should be eased in
different ways in different parts of the
country well you know from the start a
lockdown is a very crude policy
instrument to basically delay the spread
of a virus it's like pausing time to
build up the necessary public health
infrastructure and actually get the
virus back into your line of sight to
know where it is and so I think what we
need to be doing is building local
decentralized data-driven systems to
actually understand what is happening on
Skyy deepika Scottish islands what is
happening in Cornwall what is happening
in London and then actually implementing
policy interventions that react to those
I think in terms of you know lockdown
yes or no it probably won't be like that
like a light switch it'll probably be
easing of restrictions and you know I
would be as supportive of schools going
back in areas where actually it does
seem at their very low numbers of cases
what you don't want to have happen and
this is the big worry is that there's a
flood of people from an area where there
is lockdown to an area where there's
none so from urban to rural areas you
know across you know the four nations
and so actually at that point then you
know there needs to be thought given to
actually anticipating that because
that's a terrible unintended consequence
of a geographic you know different
policy st. what I'm going to be flooding
to the Scottish islands to go and have a
quick pint on the Isle of Skye if
they're able to and just finally you're
talking a lot that about data and it
seems that data is going to be a big
part of the way out of this through the
contact tracing for example looking at
the are number have we been a bit slow
on getting that data getting that
testing capacity up and getting the
analysis that we need yeah definitely I
mean I think in the UK we were stuck for
quite a long time on does testing matter
you know what should we be doing we were
also having mixed objectives is the
strategy to actually stay within NHS
capacity and everyone is exposed to this
virus or was the goal actually just to
drive numbers as low as possible and try
to keep this and suppress this virus to
very low levels and so I think now what
we can you reach consensus of is that
actually the best way out of lockdown is
to replace lockdown with test race
isolate but this requires testing
massive testing about a hundred tests
for each daily new case so this means in
the UK if we're seeing you know on
average you know you know we probably
would be needing about half a million
tests a day so is still a long way to go
unless we can get daily new cases down
during lockdown it also means tracing
capacity being able to actually you know
identify people quickly and figure out
the week before who are they in touch
with get in touch with those people
giving me no pre-symptomatic
transmission is there and the third
piece we haven't heard discussed as much
as isolation how do you actually get
people to isolate whether it's in their
homes or whether it's in other
facilities for a certain amount of time
let's say 14 days to make sure they past
the period of infectiousness and are not
passing it on to others so yes we really
need to be building all three of these
in tandem and having a public
conversation of how do we address these
because they're gonna be it's gonna
affect everybody's lives already has
affected everyone's lives and you know
people need to not understand how this
is going to develop okay thank you very
much being on the program some really
interesting stuff discussed there thank
you perfect thank you